-Welcome back to the show.
-Thank you.
-Drew, you became a dad,
by the way.
-I have become a dad.
-Congratulations.
-Thank you.
-How is dad life? How is baby?
-Yeah, I just realized we wrote
a kids book before I had kids.
I should write that now,
when I have more insight.
I remember talking to you
about that.
But it's been amazing.
He has all these little
new expressions -- He has these
two faces that he makes.
We named one of them
"The Nic Cage."
Because have you ever seen,
like, in "Face/Off"
when he does, like, the intense
face, that's what he does.
And the other one,
we call "The Coolidge."
You know, Jennifer Coolidge,
obviously, "White Lotus."
She does this, like, squinty
cute smile thing.
He does that because he knows
he's playing to the audience.
He's trying to be cutesy.
-He's cutesy.
-The Coolidge.
-So, he does two celebrity
impressions already?
-Already.
Yeah, he's better than I am.
-That's a talented baby.
Yeah, a talented baby.
-I'll bring him on the show.
-He also has this look of
confusion.
Whenever he sees my face,
he's like, "Why did Dad get
so much better looking
all of a sudden?"
[ Laughter ]
"I don't understand."
-Of course.
-Like a mirror.
-How are you as an uncle,
by the way?
-I mean, I feel like
I'm pretty great.
Right now, he doesn't do a lot,
other than make faces.
He's not crawling around,
really walking around.
-He talks a lot.
We don't know what he says.
-He's just learned --
He loves giving an applause.
So, if there's excitement
or somebody's happy, he just
starts applauding all of the
sudden, so it's pretty great.
-Eight months. He's already half
Linda's height at eight months.
-How is -- I have to mention,
how is Zooey, your girlfriend?
-Zooey sends her love.
-I love Zooey Deschanel.
-Actually --
-I love her, dude.
I worked with her --
-Whoa, back off, buddy.
-No, no, I'm just saying,
no, I worked with her.
-Last night we were FaceTiming
and she says, "Oh, my gosh --"
If you don't remember,
she said, "I was in his music
video, 'Idiot Boyfriend.'"
-"Idiot Boyfriend," was --
Thank you. Hold your applause.
-Yeah.
-One person.
-People are standing up.
People are rioting right now.
-But it was so funny because
last night, I'm like,
"Oh, my gosh,
it's been so long."
So I Googled "Zooey Deschanel,
idiot boyfriend."
Nothing came up
except my picture.
[ Laughter ]
-Yes! Yes!
-Same thing when I search
"idiot brother."
-That is so funny, buddy.
Before you were the
Property Brothers,
you guys had a lot of jobs
growing up.
And I asked you about this.
And you sent me a photo and just
really made me laugh.
One of the interesting jobs
you had, you were clowns.
-That's one of our first jobs.
Yeah, we had so much energy,
our parents were like, "get out
of the house.
Put this energy somewhere."
But we did all -- like, clowns
are -- There are different types
of clowns, different genres
or themes.
And we would try different ones.
And then Jonathan was
like a tall clown, stretch.
He was, like, on stilts.
-We realized that's not good
when you're doing, like, parades
or kids' parties where they'll,
like, tackle your legs
out from under you.
-Oh, yeah, of course.
-It hurts to fall from 10 feet.
And then Drew, he had a
character who was a sad clown.
And it was so depressing,
that eventually --
'cause we worked for
Parks and Rec.
-The parents told me to stop
doing it
because I was depressing
the kids.
-Is this -- What was the name
of your clown?
-So, I was Happy.
[ Laughter ]
-Happy the sad clown. Is this --
-Yeah.
-That's it right there. Aww.
-That's me.
-That's Drew.
-Nobody was -- We worked for
Parks and Rec,
and we're getting 10 bucks
an hour.
Then we realized they were being
paid 150 bucks
an hour for us to do it.
So, at 10 years old,
Jonathan and I opened
our own clowning business.
And we were, like, thinking
we're balling.
We're getting 100, 150 bucks
a pop for birthday parties.
-Yeah, not bad? See?
You're always in
the business mode.
-If this construction thing
doesn't work...
-Back to clowning.
-...there's always that.
We could always go back to it.
-Let's talk about "Brother vs.
Brother: No Rules."
The eighth season premiered.
What does no rules mean?
-So, Drew is the most
competitive man alive.
And he always has these --
whether it's, like, playing
games or doing something like
a competition, he makes up
rules that nobody else is aware
of that work to his advantage.
And so finally, we're like,
"No, enough of this."
And he's like,
"I've got an idea.
No rules. You can't complain."
And immediately it bit him
in the butt.
-It backfired because he brought
Zooey in.
Zooey was born in L.A.
She literally, I think,
is a secret
real-estate agent on the side
because she knows everything
about real estate.
She started combing the streets
in her car at night to try
and find the perfect house
for him buy.
I'm sure the cops were called.
-Well, that's an exaggeration,
but yes.
-No, she told me
she was combing.
-So, on this show,
so you pick a home.
You reno the home.
-Yeah.
-No matter what cost though.
-Yeah. And then we flip it
and whoever makes
a bigger profit wins.
And meanwhile, we just mess with
each other the whole time.
There are so many pranks, so
much stuff that goes wrong.
But it's a blast.
-There's a time frame
we have to get this done.
So you can't just go and buy
some $10 million house in L.A.
and then make a bigger profit.
You have to get it done fast.
-And then there's punishments
for the loser each episode
and a reward for the winner.
[ Clears throat ] The winner
in one episode got to go to
the Petersen Automotive Museum,
which has the greatest
collection of classic cars,
movie cars, you know, TV cars.
The winner got to take these --
and you never get to drive
these cars --
got to take one of them
on the road for a spin.
The loser had to wash
the "Magnum P.I." car
dressed as Magnum P.I.
[ Laughter ]
-And those shorts were short.
-Yeah, they were very short.
Tom Selleck, respect.
-How did you do that, Tom?
-Respect to Tom Selleck.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Drew and Jonathan Scott
in "Brother vs. Brother:
No Rules."
Take a look at this.
♪♪
-So, when is the front door
coming?
-So, the front door is
on its way.
We can get this thing installed
almost immediately.
-This looks suspicious.
"Congrats, Drew." Huh.
"Kinda knew you could do it,
but I still did it better.
Jonathan."
-Interesting.
-What's this?
[ Confetti cannon ]
Oh! Ow, why?!
-We love you guys.
Drew and Jonathan Scott.
Check out "Brother vs. Brother:
No Rules" Wednesdays
at 9:00 p.m. on HGTV and
the same day on Discovery+.
We'll be right back with
a performance from Myke Towers.
Stick around, everybody.
I'm the idiot boyfriend.